there's a thing in the New York Daily
News they've gone all out on it ladies
and gentlemen all out now because did
they're claiming it all comes from show
insiders so according to this I'm only
reading goods it's here
hey she's taping her face skin back yeah
and hiding the evidence with her
fabulous wings what does that even mean
well basically they've seen tape in my
makeup room so they assume that I'm
taping my face what does that mean that
what is taping your face I'm gonna tell
you a secret hotel this secret everyone
thinks I've had big boobs for many years
and I've always said oh we thought they
were bigger when they met me in person
like no they're not because I taped them
am i taped now yes that's my secret so
instead of them saying you know each
other how hard of us four four boys not
to go like that
we've all done it we all do it we do it
I mean it's like no I don't want to fall
out on your show and I don't want to
embarrass myself so my take oops
okay that I understand just if somebody
tapes her face what do they do I have no
idea cuz I've never taped my face no
types her face to their boobs
it says you've banned staffers greeting
you until you say hi first crap okay
this well yeah okay I don't when I'm on
set as a model as an executive producer
as a mentor I don't speak I still work
for photographers now that I work for
since I was 16
28 years we could talk all day long for
me to be able to have that boundary
because we've got work to do
I don't speak until lunchtime or great
time when it's you know what off-camera
we know and I understand that it's very
professional all I would say is if you
came onto Edmund oh yeah that you
wouldn't get this I like and I because I
know they can mess me up from totally
you know and what's a story what's a
look there's a whole big thing in here
about the judges in the first series yes
uh Coco and Karolina yes they're not
back nothing to do with me okay nothing
it says here at all to do with you know
your change season new mentors and I was
I've met you several times over the
years and you're always lovely you're
always really friendly and charming but
you are still I don't know where you
missed one part out the part of that
they say I'm a diva and I said that I do
my own makeup but I can tell you and
real diva would never do her own makeup
that part is it also rejected
gonna go to work in the morning I'm like
this and just be like did my makeup got
no way just no half dad in the morning
so I'm not morning so you don't do it
you do do it I do not do it I do not
touch this face I dare you I got great
makeup artists been great friends like
family is that I love and I trust just
signature all I was gonna say was what
ever I meet you very friendly nice yeah
but at the same time there is a kind of
intimidating thing of like oh that's on
you that's not on me
what's coming from using you you feel
I'm just a girl from South London and oh
that's just it it's how you want it's
what you think I'm gonna be like
the final bit of the final those wedding
cakes they were piss-poor weren't they
that's mainly for me the main point of
why I left Arsenal good answer but which
of the signings didn't you think he's
not very bad to her okay so here's the
thing using better